[Music]
Isis just claimed a major new terror
attack and the Belgian capital of
Brussels to understand why they would do
this you have to look at something that
changed for Isis about a year ago and
pretty far away in the Middle East so
Isis in the summer of 2014 had a huge
sweep across the region seizing lots of
cities starting in early 2015 the group
began to suffer some real defeats in
Syria and Iraq
plus some major cities started to come
under attack from American airstrikes
and in just a few months that lost a
quarter of its territory but this posed
more than just a military threat to Isis
it had always operated on a narrative of
victory and invincibility and it used
that to recruit and motivate fighters
over other jihadist groups and it needs
those fighters to survive the Caliphate
was losing ground so it was losing that
narrative and it needed something new to
keep that going so first they tried to
expand abroad Libya Afghanistan Yemen
those efforts all fizzled in the summer
and fall of 2015
Isis found its solution by launching
mass terror attacks against civilians
abroad and this helped the group portray
itself once again ads on the March
but then Europe faced a big problem and
how to deal with these attacks because
the hard truth is that most of these
attackers aren't foreigners they're not
refugees or migrants they're actually
European Nationals and you can't just
close the border to keep them out if
they're actually from Europe and a lot
of them are people who went and joined
Isis or other terrorist group so-called
foreign fighters and now that Isis is
losing territory those fighters are
coming home and they're bringing their
battle-hardened experience and skills
with them then these are really hard
problems to solve rooted in
socio-economic problems grievances that
go pretty deep in European society you
can't solve this with bombs or with
border clothes
so what now it seems likely that as Isis
keeps losing its territory it's going to
become something like what it was before
when America was fighting the Iraq war
in the mid-2000s not a state but still
an insurgency and a terrorist group
capable of doing terrible damage abroad
[Music]